il y a plus de 700 sortes de biscuits
sur nos tablettes d'épicerie de ceux qui
se déguisent en collation dites santé au
gourmandises les plus savoureuses on a
lancé un défi ludique mais éclairant à
trois gourmands experts vous allez voir
c'est pas toujours facile de faire des
choix
Isabelle aujourd'hui on fait une chasse
au biscuits on a lancé un défi à une
pâtissière un spécialiste en marketing
et une nutritionniste soit 10 minutes
pour choisir trois visqueux préférés et
3 à éviter panier la chance est partie
on y va
sortant du chocolat
j'irai avec le gingembre
au bleuet
première chose que mon intention c'est
lui logements est-ce que je suis plus
santé ou indulgence aujourd'hui mais
c'est pas grave ça va être au monde je
le passe nos gourmands experts ont fait
des choix mordants et tendre sur l'offre
en biscuits
de belles affaires depuis 2019 on note
une croissance de 25 à 30% dans la
consommation biscuits attribué au retour
à la maison pendant la pandémie à une
envie de confort et de se faire plaisir
à petit prix et aussi à l'envie de
recréer des souvenirs d'enfance
[Musique]
et pourquoi pas un classique très simple
mais je me connais une ou deux après ça
je peux intéresser
peut-être que le professeur de marketing
n'est simplement pas le public cible sur
le marché 12% des biscuits sont destinés
aux enfants dont les fameuses pattes
d'ours et tu sors de tes choix
en 2019 l'Observatoire de la qualité de
l'offre alimentaire à dénombrer près de
700 produits différents de ceux-là 56%
sont des biscuits réguliers c’est-à-dire
qui s'apparente à ce qu'on fait à la
maison
bonjour à tous les trois bonjour
ah il y a du caramel et il y a du
chocolat et il y a de l'érable ça il y a
une constance ici est-ce que ça a été
dur de faire un choix soit déchirant
entre
l'aspect de nostalgie souvenirs
d'enfants versus que j'aime aujourd'hui
pour moi choisir un biscuit ça dépend si
je veux le manger comme collation comme
dessert
un biscuit collation c'est un biscuit
que je vais manger pour combler une faim
donc je vais être plus exigeante plus
critique sur la valeur nutritive
générale du produit moi ça me prend du
chocolat ça me prend du chocolat ça
prend un biscuit qui croque faut que ce
soit bon puis il faut que les
ingrédients correspondent à ce que je
veux à ce qu'il y a derrière à mes
valeurs j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
remarquer qu'il y a plusieurs options
qui disent ben saveur érable et ça ça me
fait toujours un drapeau rouge alors je
me suis éloigné de ces options là
celui-ci dit du vrai sirop d'érable
celui-ci m'a attiré pour le cow-branding
la c'est un peu le professeur marketing
qui parle c'est 4 Bury 4000 chipso Roy
est-ce que des emballages qui nous
incitent à nous faire croire que le
biscuit est un aliment santé le vrai
chocolat ou vrai beurre il y a des mots
clés qui sont utilisés comme ça pour
accentuer ou donner une impression de
naturalité ou de qualité supérieure
toutes les marques ont un ou plusieurs
produits qui essaient de nous rassurer
dans notre de culpabilité
le célébration chocolat au lait du vrai
du vrai et du beurre
parce que ça pour moi c'est
incontournable la première affaire que
je regarde avant le sucre c'est le grand
avec lui Ben du vrai chocolat au lait de
temps en temps cette fois c'est plus
doux c'est plus qu'un
biscuit que je mange depuis longtemps
puis là au bleuet mon petit fruit
préféré celui-là ben je suis pas trop
biscuit au brisure de chocolat mais lui
il m'a tenté parce qu'il double chocolat
pour ma part j'ai pas vraiment regardé
la quantité de sucre tout de suite quand
je dis je mange un biscuit le sucre je
m'en fous un peu c'est surtout la
qualité des ingrédients
l'ensemble de la gamme de vital ou de
prevencia je les aime bien moi aussi ça
me prenait du chocolat parce que je
pense qu'on a ce point commun tous les
trous d'être pas mal fan de chocolat
j'ai l'impression que le biscuit au
chocolat
demeure le favori d'à peu près tout le
monde c'est un classique incontournable
sur le Top 50 biscuits les plus vendus
les deux tiers sont des biscuits au
chocolat toute marque confondue
quelque chose que je remarque trois de
la marque Leclerc donc des biscuits
d'épicerie au Mexique notamment et
biscuits
géants c'est Leclerc
qui a acquis beaucoup de marques de
biscuits dont la fameuse marque Christie
deuxième et dernier volet du défi chasse
aux biscuits les choix moins
fréquentables 3 inégociable c'est parti
récemment puis j'ai fait ah ça goutte
comme quand j'étais petite puis deux
secondes après c'est comme ah non faut
que je mange
pour moi quand un produit s'adresse à
des enfants je vais être très critique
il y a tous les additifs qu'on peut
s'imaginer qui pourrait entrer dans un
biscuit notamment plusieurs colorants
artificiels qu'on déconseille pour les
enfants
biscuits Ritz enrobé de fodge il y a pas
de vrais chocolat là-dedans en fait je
sais pas ce qui me reste ni du rythme ni
du chocolat qu'on me montre l'huile de
palme
c'est triste je peux le remettre là
c'est bon pour rien l'huile de pain
c'est mauvais pour l'environnement la
fonte la flore c'est mon rêve notre
santé à minutes que lui le BAM jusqu'à 4
j'enlève ça ça me parle un peu moins
puis pour des raisons vraiment marketing
nouvelle marque je connais pas j'ai pas
d'initiative puis la raison principale
pour laquelle je devrais l'acheter pour
moi elle est pas claire
parce que je pense qui est temps qu'on
la remette à la page qu'on revoit le
marketing
alors on sort vos trois choix à éviter
légumes et fruits gâteau carottes je
comprenais plus le produit j'adore
le futur d'Isabelle se retrouvait dans
les choix préférés
on est fan et quand on est fan de
caramel on est fan mélangez les deux
ensemble j'ai peine à croire que
l'expérience sera satisfaisante pour les
deux fans oui mais là je pense que je
devrais aller faire l'épicerie avec mes
collègues
alors un petit dégustation qui
sollicitent vos papilles gustatives et
la nostalgie du pirates
conclusion du défi nos trois experts
s'entendent sur un seul biscuit celui
qu'on fait soi-même il y a tellement
d'apprentissages quand tu fais de la
cuisine beaucoup vont dire ben on n'a
pas le temps ouais mais prenez une heure
par semaine faites vos biscuits pour la
semaine faites une recette de pâtes de
biscuits de base quand on fait nos
rouleaux on met ça congélateur on les
coupe en revenant de l'école la
satisfaction que ça donne un enfant la
force que ça amène à dire être capable
de me nourrir je suis capable de
biscuits la fierté que tu développes
c'est que c'est bon pour tout cuisiner
[Musique]